okay now
in a meta manner we've gotten to the why
of act that is why should people who are
listening slash watching to this care
about act so the value of act let's get
into the what of act what is act
can you break it down step by step how
does someone go through the process of
act
how does the person go through the
process of act well it depends it
depends which
way you do it right so which treatment
delivery format
you're doing and so it could be
one-on-one therapy it could be workshops
it could be online you know okay i'll
give you an example for me i was dealing
with the obsessive thoughts that came
from rumination of
what the heck is reality and then
questioning my own and then
i started to use one of the analogies
what's great about act is that it has
these visual analogies yeah so one of
them is thoughts as if they're
passengers on a bus and you're the
driver of the bus and if you were to
simply quiet the thoughts or tell them
to shut up or go away or be distressed
about them and place an undue amount of
attention to them then they become a bit
louder much like an obstreperous
audience member would become more
agitated the more that you speak to them
perhaps what you should do is simply
acknowledge their existence say oh i see
that you're there which is why by the
way i want to get to is acknowledgement
a better term than acceptance but we can
get to that later that's a very good
question
because accepting to me seems to take
those thoughts on and say oh no your
reality should be questioned and perhaps
so-and-so is not true it's so anyway
that's a very important question and i
hope we get to it we'll get to look at
this written down
and so
then i would view those thoughts as
visually as passengers on a bus and i
would say okay well i'm going to direct
this bus where my values are and
initially i missed out on the values
portion so it wasn't as effective until
i
then where am i going with the bus that
to me is where the values come in and
why should i even go there so initially
i missed out on the values that later
when i added that it became more
effective for me okay so that's how it
worked for me
and i think initially before that i was
doing something that didn't work which
you mentioned earlier thought
suppression i did i had a rubber band on
anytime i would have these thoughts that
would give me anxiety i would do this
self-administered adversive therapy
which i thought worked for thoughts and
it apparently it doesn't it rebounds
later maybe initially works but so i
stopped that and found act and then i
saw some success so that's my personal
case
with act so given that
that's what i mean can you take us
through an example of how someone
listening may employ this in their own
life and perhaps how one should apply it
in their own life is too broad and maybe
you just want to take a specific example
and say
you understand the question
so i'll start broad and maybe go a
little more narrow but tell me if this
is the wrong direction
so i'll share the the
kind of key features right
first of all
a rich and meaningful life
and act is about what you want
not what you don't want
it's about going for something that you
value and care about
rather than escaping from or avoiding
experiences that you don't want okay
and so for example
patients will come in or people will
come in and they'll say
i don't want to feel anxious anymore
i don't want to feel pain anymore i
don't want to feel sadness or guilt
anymore
people are quick and automatically will
tell you all the things that they don't
want
and
our medical field and in general our
society is like okay well don't
let's figure out how you can not feel
this way right let's figure out how you
can not feel this way think this way etc
act will say well okay
if you weren't in pain
what would you be doing instead
if this pain we're not getting in the
way of living
as it is right now what would you be
doing
if you weren't so anxious
what would you be doing
right if you weren't so guilt-ridden
what would you be doing you're trying to
get away from
symptom focus to
what do you want to be doing in your
life if those things were not there
so that's the first thing
then there's the issue of how to manage
emotions and thoughts
and our society has trained us to kind
of think
or to to respond to emotions and
thoughts that we don't like by pushing
them away
right if i tell my friend
i feel really anxious
what's the first thing they're going to
say kurt
about what
if i tell a friend i'm like
i'm
what are you anxious about
okay they might say what are you anxious
about and i'll say i'm really anxious
about giving this talk
then what what will they say
oh don't worry about it you'll do fine
you go girl
yep exactly don't feel anxious you're
fine right
don't worry about it you're you're fine
it's like so all the implicit messages
we get
is don't feel that way right or if or if
i'm saying i feel really sad right now
don't feel sad it's going to be fine
right
we are taught even all the
advertisements about antidepressants
anxiolytics are you anxious
are you sad
this can take it away
right this can take it away so we've
been programmed to think it's not okay
to feel this way
and so
the problem
is that both emotions
and thoughts things inside our body
that people cannot see
are mostly involuntary
these are mostly conditioned or
programmed responses
to certain circumstances in our life
and the idea in act is to simply notice
them for what they are
and not struggle against them so let me
give you two examples
number one if i say and i'm going to
give you a very benign one
mary had a little
lamb
one
red white and
i don't know this part blue
blue
one two
three
that's programmed
if i tell you kurt
do not say lamb
after mary had a little could you not
think lamb
could you do that
i mean i can't i don't know i imagine no
i imagine the answer is no okay mary had
a little think of something else
panda
okay i'll come back to that you will
always
always have lamb in your head
because our brain does not work by
subtraction
our brain works by addition
so trying to undo something is
impossible actually
if i told you right now um a good friend
of yours just got into an accident
what would that trigger for you i feel
anxious
and
worried
could you undo that
i don't know some of the buddhists say
that with enough mindfulness training
one can get to a point where
stimuluses no longer provoke you at
least not to the same degree
i've seen some video online of a monk
self a lighting so setting oneself a
light it's calmly and then just dying i
don't know how the
extreme amount of discipline
so
absolutely it's true
what you learn is
how to respond to these things in new
ways
it's not that they stop showing up
they still show up
but when they show up and you're not as
consumed by it
your attention is not so narrowly
focused on it
it doesn't have as much of an impact on
you right
so
if i'm
so i see this for example in a lot of my
pain patients or my chronic medical
condition patients like
their life has been so
fixated on the medical condition on the
pain on
you know getting things you know getting
the right meds getting this getting that
that they've lost track of the rest of
their life and they're depressed
they're not focused on their family as
much they're not focused on their career
as much they're not focused on things
that bring them joy
it's like they're narrowly fixated on
one aspect of their life which is the
condition or the illness or the
medical problem and i'm saying step back
and recognize that there is more to you
than that
but if this is the only part you're
going to fixate on of course it's going
to like consume you
and paradoxically occur
the more you open up your life
and do things like these patients with
medical conditions
when they stop fixating just on the
medical condition and start doing other
things again
paradoxically the pain goes down
it's the same thing with anxiety
when you start engaging in life more
and you allow the anxiety to be there
without it being kind of the thing that
drives whether you do something or not
paradoxically the anxiety goes down a
question that occurred to me is when you
were mentioning that you were feeling
anxiety and by the way i i'm extremely
nervous generally when i'm doing these
interviews as well
and also being interviewed for sure and
extreme oh my god i don't i generally
say no to people interviewing me so i
don't have as much courage as you
perhaps i should muster some what
occurred to me was does this technique
can i say something sure sure
perhaps you will choose to muster some
you don't have to do anything right it's
even that subtle comment about perhaps i
should
you don't have to do anything
do you choose to is there something
about it that matters to you in that
it's a very different experience to say
i have to do this versus i'm choosing
this
willingly
even if it's going to elicit anxiety in
me that's great that may help me in the
future or i may choose to allow that to
help me in the future i don't know
what's the right response to that but
regardless where i was getting it was
does this technique simply allow you to
cope or does it ameliorate the anxiety
because those are two different issues
yeah absolutely they are and um
that's the paradox of this
although act does not aim
to reduce symptoms
it's asking you to willingly sit with so
that's the term i use instead of
acceptance because i'll tell you why
if i'm willing to have the anxiety
that's instead of acceptance if i'm
willing
to have the anxiety
in service of something that matters to
me right
that's the goal the goal is me being
willing to experience something
difficult because it's in service of
something that matters
but when i do that repeatedly
paradoxically my anxiety goes down
it's not the goal the goal is not to
reduce my anxiety the goal is for me to
live a life that's meaningful and rich
but what's paradoxical and what all the
research is showing is that
when you do that
actually anxiety goes down
and i'll give you examples from my
studies because so i'm funded by the
national institutes of health and the va
department the veterans affairs
department
and nih and the va
for a long time has focused on symptom
reduction right so when i apply for
grants i say
i'm going to do this act intervention
and i'm going to explore whether this
reduces depression and anxiety
right i say that in the grant actually i
want to make sure
i reduce depression or anxiety but when
i'm actually in the treatment actually
doing the treatment i don't say that
ever
not once do i say
okay you know you guys met criteria for
depression which they all do
to be in the study for example and my
goal is for you not to meet criteria i
never say anything about that
it's it's a
political decision it's a funding
decision that i put it as the outcome
but paradoxically the intervention even
though i never talk about reducing
anxiety and depression
i talk about helping them live a rich
and meaningful life and to let them
explore their emotions and not be afraid
of them
but most of my studies i have found
significant reductions in depression and
an anxiety and improvements in meaning
and purpose